the state of Utah faces growing
opposition over newly passed drunk
driving law it lowers a legal
blood-alcohol limit from 0.08 to 0.05
now that makes it the lowest threshold
in the nation the law is set to go into
effect late next year but some
businesses are already fighting back as
the National Restaurant lobbying group
launches a new ad campaign Carter Evans
is at a craft brewery in Salt Lake City
Carter good morning good morning
according to the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration a
160-pound man could hit the limit after
just two drinks of one hour now
lawmakers are hoping the new lower limit
will convince people to think twice
about driving drunk opponents of the new
law want to convince people who come
here it could have serious legal
consequences the new ad campaign is
aggressive warning tourists traveling to
Utah come for vacation leave on
probation
it's a jab at the state's new drunk
driving law reluctantly I think they
have a point
Doug hoffland is CEO of squatters
brewery in Salt Lake City he worries the
ads and the upcoming lower blood alcohol
limit will scare people away what do you
think people are going to do there
they're not going to come because they
can't drink as much that's what we're
afraid of we think conventions will stop
coming here and what's going to happen
is every other state is going to come
and try and steal our business State
Representative norm Thurston sponsored
the bill and says it will save lives by
deterring people from drinking and
driving the public safety impact of this
is so compelling that it's worth doing
even though you've already got the
lowest DUI death rate in the country
we're not a zero the National
Transportation Safety Board has
recommended a point O 5 blood-alcohol
limit since 2013 Utah will be the first
state to adopt it there are a lot of
businesses and restaurants that are
concerned about how this is going to
impact their bottom line it's it's hard
to feel too much sympathy for people
whose business model is to profit from
people who choose to drink and drive
none of us are trying to sell the people
to drive drunk
we are responsible business operators
and none of us
that this bill really and truly is about
stigmatizing alcohol and punishing those
who serve it the new ads backed by the
American Beverage Institute
blatantly point that out this law
targets moderate responsible social
drinkers and it doesn't target the high
BAC hardcore drunk drivers who cause the
vast majority of alcohol-related
fatalities predominantly Mormon Utah is
known for an intricate web of liquor
laws that have included selling low
alcohol near beer and setting up
so-called Xion curtains to shield
children from seeing bartender's mix
alcoholic drinks and now restaurant
owners say an even more difficult
business climate is brewing tourism and
hospitality are a major major industry
in the state of Utah I'm terrified of
the economic effects that could have now
opponents are hoping to either repeal
the law before it goes into effect or
lessen the penalties lawmakers say it's
already having an impact here even
though it doesn't go into effect until
2018 because it has already lowered DUI
arrests and they're now hoping other
states will follow suit Norah all right
Carter thank you so much